when was the last time somebody confused
you with another famous person someone
came up a few weeks ago and they were
like I loved you in sex education that
show was so cool and I was like oh I'm
so sorry it's not me
I just love that oh sorry it's not me
because it is like a running thing now
it's sort of like a running joke now but
have Margot Robbie and Emma Mackie been
seen in the same room so I don't know if
you know but in real life you have your
own Conspiracy Theory online I do yeah
Emma Mackie are the same person and you
speak French in this film which she is
her French is far better than mine that
will put the conspiracy to rest
immediately she also speaks Spanish and
she also has an amazing singing voice
and I cannot speak Spanish I'm not
fluent in French and I don't have an
amazing singing voice we're not the same
person but we are friends and I love her
I love her too Emma Mackie and I get
told we look alike all the time so and
did you manage to kind of play off that
with Barbie you'll have to wait and see
yeah I love that answer